magic has HIV yeah positive oh Magic got
HIV and that's that's different that's
different no hi early stages AIDS is
you're [__] that's a Pokemon evolution
yes super it's super saiyan HIV can you
bring it back can you take AIDS and turn
that [__] back to HIV fully compromised
no it's yeah it's open it's open do we
have what comes after AIDS yet yeah
heaven or oh yeah come on
buddy did you see in Palm Springs a very
popular gay uh G this is crazy the
monument that they they trolling bro
they they got to be trolling they they
sort of mar the King s like my beer AIDS
Memorial bro that AIDS Memorial looks
like an [__] or a Jolly Rancher wait
what not a Jolly Rancher Lifesaver life
sa you know it's
[Laughter]
not I mean yeah that's that's crazy
that's their thing now because you don't
know any name of a
sculptor until they do some [__] like
that everybody talking that's
interesting yeah I don't know the name
of a sculptor ever I don't know who
sculpted that Michelangelo like
[__] used to have some clout
back in the day now it's just like but I
don't know who did the Martin Luther
King one I don't know who did this one
when we were talking about the story
they were saying the guy's name I
understand your point which is like if
you want attention for your work you
have to do something that's really going
to cause controversy and back in the day
causing controversy might have been uh
having like a political position M and
now it's making something look like an
[__] or making it look like what was
the what was the
uh his arms and like it just looked
weird look like he was getting head oh
that's right yeah cuz you see him like
embracing the head is kind of foul low
key like if you are doing it just for
the clout you're kind of disrespecting
MLK's wife yeah he disrespecting Getta
and he cheated we know this so like come
on we don't need to draw attention to
this was in the movie in yo but maybe
that would have been Martin Luther King
favorite statue of cuz he could just
imagine any girl's head you know what I
mean it was just arms at that point you
know now this guy hey that sculptor that
might have been Alle yo good job this
one this one's kind of tough like why
like if you're doing a Aid sculpture I
feel like that's not an easy sculpture
the thing they love the most but what is
that is that a white blood cell oh it
could be that too is it a te- cell if
it's a te- cell that makes sense that's
that's mocking the most no that's the
last one left oh man that's your last T
ultimate self godamn that's far yeah I
don't know I mean what would your Aid
statue be would you make one if they
approach you and say hey Andrew we need
a we need a Aid statue hpal [__] a girl
with AIDS or
don't I will what I will I'll do it
where [__] a girl with AIDS or never
lose your
virginity well can you you can [__] with
AIDS and not get AIDS right yeah if you
hold your ureal clothes with your
strength if you use strength the whole
year you read for clo [__] with a deep
breath you won't you w't get it is that
how it
works
[__] that's a good ass question [__] a
girl at age or Never Lose Your vinia now
can you use a condom I don't think
that's fair for hypothetical okay condum
obviously you probably done
it [__] you I'm not saying I'm not
saying statistically I'm not saying you
haven't done it but you might you
probably didn't so one would I ever use
a
condom
you [__] God come on BR yo the yo the
statistics showed it we probably got
burned yo
well not y'all stop trying to just you
just trying to get everybody in your
[__] can we normalize getting burned no
can we just
[Music]
normaliz been I didn't tell you when my
came out
hot no I've heard this my P came out hot
I went to the doctor I got my shot yeah
you talked about this with I don't know
if about had clamydia cuz you either get
the shot or get tested for it I said
give me that shot my boy you you had it
I didn't have it you had it but we don't
know I have it or not H your hot that's
crazy it wasn't hot bro it just felt
like I always had a little more but I
couldn't get it out oh no yeah don't you
hate that y'all never had chyia from a
[__] I don't think so I I just had
jockage I had that one time how'd you
get that one they claim it was [__]
like not drying off all the way I've got
I've gotten jockage yeah you never got
that stop trying to relate to
STD I have got that no no
we're let's go athletes get that yeah
real athletes Mark was so hyp you could
share a [__] story
bro my doctor call Sports dick that's
what what happens that's what athletes
get what happened bro literally this is
the most insane this most insane thing
ever I got jockage no way yeah how old
this like in Miami this three years
ago I never told you this son C
no no chickenpox I forget to
get okay bust it down go go that's the
problem I think that's what happened no
I literally bro we might need to
vaccinate these kids
maner I think it I I don't know what it
comes from it's like loud a little it
came out of that thing but no it's like
you wear like tight underwear and then
you don't take it off after you sweat
and then you get jocket right is that
how it works or if you're sweating and
you don't dry it all the way or after
showers not drying it all the way and
[__] like that yeah I don't dry is it
chafing or is it like a bacteria I think
it's like a like a fungal that makes
sense it's warm like moist environment
bacteria live okay so Miami how'd you
get rid of it bro I had to get cream but
I had to go to the doctor and my girl
literally was like what is that no way
and I was like what are you talking
about she's like be honest you telling
me I won't be mad I was like what well
that kind of fire that is and I was like
second free was like I Could Have
Cheated this whole time
and might have it like if you know how
she's going to deal with it but then she
was mad at me and she was like babe it's
just a little more jock you know I'm
talking I got to add it on I got to keep
that in mind for the future that's run
it back my trying to trap you to tell
her the truth and then going to be mad
anyway yeah I think so that was one of
those maybe yeah it
probably gave you
that yo I should have flipped it on her
I go yeah how did I get this how did I
get this that's genius bro you could be
honest with me mad yeah what jock were
you with that gave me the [__] did that
happen huh but no I I got it and I had
to go to the doctor and
literally like she my girl didn't come
in and the woman comes in with me and
and like the nurse or whatever and she's
like yeah it's jockage and I was like
okay for sure right she's like yeah and
she's like do you have other sexual
partners I was like No And like the
nurse had my back and I was like okay
tell her this guys we're gonna take a
break real quick because I got to tell
you about exter this is I don't care
what wallet you have you need one of
these if you don't have a wallet and
you're looking you get yourself an extra
if you have some [__] designer
product Christian Dior whatever wallet
you still need one of these and I'm
going to tell you all the reasons why
first of all quick card access take a
look at that ba there you go all your
cards pull out whatever one you need
that's just convenient second it don't
take up much space you put it in your
side pocket in your living third and
this is the most important thing it has
two key tracker features first of all
that means it is trackable worldwide if
you lose your wallet or somebody steals
it you could just call that [__] up it
works on uh voice activation with Siri
uh Alexa Google home all that [__] and
most importantly again this is what I'm
telling you even if you got a nice
wallet you need one of these this has
RFID protection which means if you're
traveling if you're a tourist and in one
of these cities we're afraid you're
going to get pickpocketed or scammed or
people are just going to skim your
information like that Boop like that
Boop this protects you against debt so
no matter what wallet you have get
yourself an extra keep yourself safe it
is convenient it is the best wallet you
can get and you can get a discount
because we're flagrant and we always
hook you up go to shop. xer.com
flagrant and get 25% off sitewide with
the code flagrant again that is
shop. EK
s.com flagrant get 25% off and now let's
get back to this exclusive patreon clip
if you want to watch the full episode
come hang out with the boys you can do
that at
patreon.com flagrant or patreon.com /
fan 2 come join the [__] Army it's
the best army to be a part of dud this
is every time you go to the hospital
remember the chicken the chickenpox
story yeah did you tell that on the pot
yeah yeah that one was that one was
worse but they thought it was monkey pox
yeah they thought he got chickenpox
during the monkey pox epid you haven't
told this story on the pot I think I did
yeah yeah I know I did I don't know I
literally got chickenpox no you came to
[__] Burning Man yes like the week
after I got chickenpox I went to the
doctor the woman during monkey pox
epidemic the the heart of it the PE we
need a sculpture for that and then they
came in and the woman looks at me and
she's like oh [__] I'll be right back
walks out comes back in with two other
people full hazmat
suits and then they're like assessing
the pimples and [__] and they're like
have you had any of their sexual
partners I was like No And they're like
have you have you have you had like
intercourse like samesex intercourse and
I was like that's part of the first
question that's that secondly also my
girl is right here I'm not going to say
it in front of her you [__] crazy and
they're like okay well we're just going
to swab to test anyway and I was like
well I have all the you know co-founders
for [__] chickenpox and they're like
well we just want to double check and
make sure and then they did the test and
then I fixed the chickenpox myself they
called me two weeks later they're like
it's not monkey pox fortunately it's
chickenpox and I was already in Bernie
man I was like hold on you I thought you
found out that it was monkey it wasn't
monkey pox before you came to Bernie man
yeah I did how what that it wasn't
monkey pox no I knew it was chickenpox I
mean you can't get monkey pox if you're
not having gay sex at least add up now
so if you're not having gay sex you're
not having monkey Puck was there another
way that you could tell that it was the
chicken pux I mean it just had all the
[__] so I knew it was chickenpox and
then I got it fixed and then went to my
actual doctor not like the clinic or
whatever and then he was like yeah it's
crush it over you're fine you can go to
the thing [__] Primacare retards
sayur cares what do you mean I could get
a job there right there yeah I think I
could get a job at a City MD and they
just look up WebMD that's what like they
not I don't think they real do real
doers will do that which is scary but
yeah I think these Urgent Care guys so
what's the what's the deal Urgent Care
you need like one Doctor Who's
responsible for the Urgent Care and then
everybody else can be a nurse and a UPS
guy that comes in that never leaves and
that's who works there I'm almost
positive it's all the ones that go to
med school in the Caribbean they go to
theg k how look down how look down on is
that in the medical community so I have
friends who are actually good doctors
who went to med school in the Caribbean
but the thing is to get you take an MCAT
4 med school called boards and to get in
you need so much higher of a score if
you're coming from the Caribbean it's
like again like the SATs for doctors
that like if you came from the Caribbean
here you crush those tests and you're
probably pretty smart maybe you [__]
off too much in undergrad partied too
much whatever but then if you don't so
like a 120 out of 180 or whatever 200
whatever will get you in in the US you
need like a 170 175 and coming so those
guys usually are actually smart they
just [__] off an undergrad and
undergrad doesn't make you a good doctor
that's organic chemistry
you know physiology matters but like a
lot of physics not going to make you a
good doctor so those guys a lot of times
I'll Trust I'll be like oh you had to
really crush your medical SATs to put it
whatever to get here but it is looked
down upon as [__] amongst the doctor
community and that's why the bar is
higher for them to get in yeah gotta oh
I actually respect and the medical
schools here are probably better but but
again you the the standardized test that
levels a playing field you got to do way
better on that so much better that it's
like you must know your [__]
I got it okay that kind of makes sense I
just had a a sphere thought by the
way okay the the MSG sphere and what's
it called do we curate a
show for this sphar that's how much he
were't
listened a question he asked me he asked
me is well bothers me he wanted me to
tell him the
information that was so great that's
what's insulting about it you see what's
insulting about it I the I didn't talk
voluntarily so that was N I listened to
the whole question I got the information
that I needed I responded the question I
have an amazing fully thought out idea
about something completely unrelated to
what you were just talking about it's
already worked out in my head I got the
beginning middle and
end but I was listening to though I was
listen god dude wow that was unnecessary
I listen and I responded no you you
didn't respond that's not true I did say
I did respond about the higher
score what when he finished talking yeah
I responded yo the spear though no I
didn't it went run back and tape I
literally cuz I knew I had a spar thing
I want to say but I was like I can't
just say that cuz it's going to sound
like I'm not listening so let me just
repeat the last [__] he said and then
I'll say my Spar thing there you go
that's what it was but I did respond I
did hear that thing you treated me like
a wife yo I'm not treat you are my wife
bro I'm your wife we married Bro we
married that's true that's true [__]
that's true all right but you inspired a
[__] great sphere thought okay what
is it assisted suicide from listening to
that long
ass no no no I forgot this fear thing
I'll be honest with you couldn't have
been that great of an idea it probably
wasn't it probably wasn't I don't think
it's that good for the performer